(audience applauding and cheering)
- [Kelly] It's been a minute.
You were here a bit ago.
- [Édgar] Yeah.
And actually it, it was
during COVID, remember?
- [Kelly] I know.
- It was like a sci-fi-
- The screen, yes.
- Yeah, the screens, yeah.
It's so good to see.
- It was when I talked
to everybody via screen.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yes. I like you physically
in person more, yes.
- [Édgar] Absolutely, yeah.
- We can like hug, yeah.
- Thank you, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, So good to see the audience.
- So wait, it's New Year's now,
so what do y'all do in Venezuela?
Do you have any special things y'all do?
- In Venezuela? Many.
There is one that I used
to do when I was a kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it really paid off.
- [Kelly] What?
- You go around, I mean,
when the clock hits 12.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You hug everybody and
then you take a suitcase
and go around the block
running around the block
and that will give you a lot
of travels during the year.
- [Kelly] I like this.
- So I did it a lot when I was a kid
and now I'm traveling all the time.
- You're traveling all the time.
- It works. Do it, kids.
- So yeah, it works.
- That's why it pays off.
- Do it.
(audience applauds)
- There's something with
grapes as well, right?
- [Édgar] Ah, yeah.
- 'Cause I think they do
the same thing in Mexico.
'Cause I was in Mexico
once and they were like,
all of a sudden, there
were grapes at the table.
- [Édgar] Yeah.
- And I think they do the
same thing in Venezuela.
- The same thing.
- [Kelly] I had no idea.
- So it's 12 grapes for
the months of the year.
And it's 12, yeah? It's 12 months, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah
Yeah, of course. (chuckles)
- There are 12 months, yes.
- [Édgar] Yeah, exactly.
So it's 12 wishes.
- Yeah.
- And then, right before
the clock hits 12,
then you have to eat them.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And make a wish for each grape.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I thought whenever I was
doing it, I heard someone in,
because I was drinking tequila.
(audience laughs)
- [Edgar] Yeah, of course.
- And I heard them say,
"You have to eat it in the first minute."
- Yeah.
- But I think it's actually
you have to eat them each minute,
like the first 12 minutes.
So I was just, I wanted
my wishes to come true.
- [Édgar] I was just like you,
- I'm so fast.
- Yeah. I was doing it.
I always doing it in
the 12 seconds before.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I did it.
I, yeah. Somebody was like,
no, no, no.
It was like one a minute
and I was like, no, I didn't hear that.
(audience laughs)
Anyway. I got my wishes
though. So, there you go.